this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart omax
and odd one out comics more on that
later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here
doing it in the night pants studios i am
ryan
brian.com ryan sickler on all social
media
and as always i want to sincerely say
thank you to everyone out there thank
you for
however you support the show whether
it's through sponsors merch
comments just nicey whatever it is thank
you for real it makes a difference right
now is a strange time so i appreciate
the positivity back i really do
make sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel we've got time codes in there if
you want to jump to different stories
make sure if you have a story or someone
you know has a story you think needs to
be told and heard
sign up for the patreon show and submit
your story honeydewpodcast
gmail.com all the links are on the
honeydewpodcast.com
i can't thank you enough night pants
nation you guys so i want you to know
you sold out the manufacturer's [ __ ]
night pants like those people are like
what's going on out there and it's it's
a revolutions what the [ __ ] going on
so thank you for your
comfortable support um facebook fan page
all that stuff
it's all there um as far as
what we do here if you're new we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers today
i'm very excited to have my guest first
time here on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen
please welcome the one and only tom
arnold y'all thank you ryan thank you
young man right now what what are night
pants thank you night pants
are you probably call them pajamas or
lounge oh i like that but i put them on
at night yeah call them my night pants
put them on during the day if you're fat
or if i wear them that sounds like
something that many of the kids would
like
i haven't been in a pair of jeans since
yeah this [ __ ] hit since yeah
well you know and also i thought you bet
night pads like that you could see at
night
when you're out looting and uh sure you
know uh
you know i do a good idea though it is a
good job that's knight pad's job
she's the leader of him at night and you
get a good move you know uh
uh it's good to be here i know you from
comedy right
we do yeah factories where we first
there you go
i did your show there that's how i met
joel mandelkorn
oh yes joe bettacore my old assistant
what's that yeah well this is still
working with joel he's a great dude
he is a great dude yeah well you know
can i tell a joel's story do you mind if
i tell you i don't can i say one thing
real quick um
mandy johnson joel's partner has a
fantastic book out called super serious
um go it's i've promoted it go find it
on my ig
wherever and get it it's a great book
about alternative comedy
in los angeles she is so talented well
they you know joel started uh working
for me joel battle court and
uh uh you know uh i was living over here
there's a you know i've been divorced uh
uh uh only four times and there is a
building called 1221 ocean boulevard
it's on the ocean it's beautiful
and it's where a lot of uh divorce
people live or uh it's a great you know
temporarily
britney spears is my next door neighbor
then and uh
she was actually married to uh kevin
federline at the time but you see a lot
of people
in and out it'd be a great building to
do a tv show about
because you hear and see a lot of great
things in there
uh it's sort of like that in between
jobs like yeah
that building yeah but it's in between
jobs was an apartment company
yeah yeah i had a it's a beautiful
building i had a delightful time there
and uh
uh you know my friend there's a guy
named david foster who is
probably the the best music composer
of all time the people he's worked with
michael jackson andre bocelli you just
he has the docu there's a documentary
about david foster
he is the best of the best that he's
been married
more than once and i love all of his
wives and uh
he was uh but he's just he's an amazing
human being
who's uh he's worked with every big uh
bandit
and he was in between marriages too and
he came downstairs he had a girlfriend
and
he may have married her probably anyway
he came downstairs and there's a
an office area big the people come in to
do their work to do whatever and he kind
of was like
hey tom how you doing he's kind of like
shh and he called uh
another lady who was not his uh
girlfriend
and he wasn't like engaged to the the
woman and he's like
you know he's talking to this other guy
he was in between
and uh he's like keep it you know of
course i'm gonna not say anything
and then about he went upstairs and
about 20 minutes later
his girlfriend came down and she called
it guy
and i just thought that is the funniest
thing in the world
and uh and then i have um
and the uh uh ryan reynolds lived there
too
at the time and yeah he's a great he
worked out in the gym there and i saw
him one day and then
then he went on uh uh uh
no and i saw him and i don't think he
saw me because he went on code and
o'brien
and he he was on the cover of like men's
health
magazine looking super fit and uh
coded pulled that out and and he and he
said got such great self-deprecating
humor ryan rails i love him
he's amazing dude and he said uh he
wanted to make fun of himself because he
didn't like it he was uncomfortable that
coated pulled that out because he looked
so amazing
and he said but when i let out my
breath i look like tom arnold he just
said that
and uh and then i saw him in the gym
and said yeah thanks a lot and
uh but i played it tough and so then he
i'm in 4c [ __ ] and then but ted
uh came to my door
upstairs a note and a bottle of
uh champagne of dom perignon said listen
that was a classless thing for me to do
uh i apologize ryan reynolds it was a
bottle of champagne
and then i took that note and sent it
back to his room saying
i'm a recovering guy
[Music]
would make a joke about me i've always
been like that like
you have to be since i started this
business you know
for someone to make a joke about you for
johnny carson or
anyone you know uh what if it's funny
you know that was so funny and then to
be able to keep the
keep it going they got to know who the
[ __ ] you are yeah so anyway you're out
there
yes they do and when you're david people
though so
joel matacord became my assistant based
on his credentials and mandy was his
girlfriend and and you know and she's
very cute
very smart and so anyway joel starts
working for me and he's sitting in front
of me where that apartment working
and i did have a wife at the time i
can't remember if it was julie or
shelby it was in between roseanne and my
last wife
and uh we're sitting there and uh joel
uh
has uh uh uh joel has a a
you know and you want to address
everything when you meet him like hey
let's just get this out of the way not a
big deal
and i said you know i think that joel
may have had uh
he might i said to my wife let's just
say it's
shelby let's say so hey i think uh i
think joel might have a
what do you call uh a uh uh
a cleft uh palette and she's like oh
i go i'm gonna ask him she says what
don't know don't i'm leaving i go no no
i think he
i think it'd be cool i think i just got
to address it i think i just she's like
uh
do not say i go no i think he's cool
like i would want somebody to address if
i was
you know was missing arm or something i
think we're gonna be dead so he's
sitting behind him so i go like
yesterday
hey joel and she's still in there she's
like oh i
freaking hate you hey joel listen uh hey
and then i saw his email yeah joe joel's
email address was
cleft clips and i was like yeah joel
hey so uh
well this email address is yours
wow that's interesting where uh
where did uh what's that where did you
come up with that andy
and he turned around he goes tom
i have a hair lip and then i go what
i had no i i what are you talking about
and he's just busting me sore but he was
so
talented i remember one time we're at
the uh or at the burials hotel
and uh joaquin phoenix came up to me and
uh
joaquin fees is one of the well he's a
brilliant actor
but he's one of the best uh human beings
you'll ever know and
really uh is of service to a lot of
people in in our community and it is a
great human being
and and you talk about a low uh you know
i was filming true lies uh back in i
think 93 and
and uh you know i i mean if you just
hear his voice on the 911 call when his
brother
uh died on sunset boulevard outside of
the viper room i mean
how do you ever uh
recover from that you do we go on i
don't know
uh but uh you know and uh
and so i know him as being a very on
honest uh wonderful uh human being
anyway he comes over and i'm sitting
there with joel at
at the poll out she comes over gives me
a hug we talk a little bit
and joel's like joel battlecourt always
acted too cool
for school like hey no big deal he's not
impressed and then but
with joaquin phoenix i introduced him to
joel and joel's like
there's hearts coming out of his eyes
cartoon
and uh and joel said no he is
joaquin is the because there there's
there's apparently they
have his lip to he is the king of the
i don't you know of them whatever so
that was the one time
that was the one time he was uh
impressed but you know they
i've had a lot of assistance that have
moved on to do
amazing things joel and uh one guy
did spongebob and what several what
emmys and
you know uh you know that said that
that means i'm old that means uh you
know
i want to talk about that yeah because
but but i have to but i'm here today
to talk about you know you don't always
realize how dark
things are or that there's sort of a fog
in your life i mean you you you get up
and go
you go at it and uh i also think it's
important
to not uh carry ghosts into to not fight
ghosts in your adult life
from your childhood a lot of people
they're still battling those ghosts and
you know i always said i wanted to be a
father my father was
20 when he was 22 he was a single father
and i was four my sister was three my
brother was one
and uh and and uh it you know
he worked in a factory we're from a very
blue-collar
small town and uh and where
in ottumwa iowa southeast iowa
and uh uh so can i ask you he's a single
dad do you see your mom and i was a
split club
no no no no no my parents my mom was a
an alcoholic like me and uh married
seven times very chaotic
life and they went to court at first and
my dad's parents
uh who were paying for both and
it came time to put me on the stand to
basically say
who do you love more your mom and your
dad and then dad just couldn't do it
and so you remember this the next day i
do remember that
very very very little but it's also
documented and also
um after my my last divorce i kind of
went through
all the stuff and and uh you know
read everything which which makes it
important to leave some
some uh digital footprints for your kids
too about your life but
uh you know he he the day after this
uh my dad gave up in court he's like i
can't do that
and then the day after that my mother
came to my dad's office and said here's
the keys to the house
the kids are there at the babysitter
there you're so
that was a big moment that's a big
moment because
looking back for me you know i'm now the
oldest of seven kids and
you know she pat she passed away when
she was
probably it's you know 20 30 years ago
so you know as as you know if you
continue to abuse your body with alcohol
and just that hard life and smoking
there's a lot of smoking where i'm from
you know it wears out on you you know uh
that's what happened with her and we had
a very acrimonious relationship at the
end of her life
i remember uh it was when i
early on with rosanna's marriage and i
was gonna make i was gonna try to
to work you know i made overtures we
talked or this and that
because i'd gotten sober and i knew how
to do that
was she was she out of your life
completely or was it an in and out
well i mean i was you grew up i would go
say hi to her and
you know i didn't uh you know stop by
here and there
yeah i stopped as here and i did but did
she live close
well she lived in iowa how far away i
split i mean we had a uh
i was very she lived very close i
remember as a kid
everyone's parents did yeah they stayed
close
well you did our town was so small i
mean i but i it was still a million
miles away from my dad's house yeah
and i i remember going to look for her
and going house to house
very small and uh and finding her was on
the couch with a guy
and but you'd go out and then i remember
again almost getting hit by a car
and just being taken back to my dad's
and you just
you know uh you you're looking for
something
and you make these uh parents uh heroes
you know
because she'd always say i'm coming back
i'm coming to get you
and you know i also have to be honest i
had wonderful grandmothers
me too you know i love her who just love
me unconditionally her mother
and my dad's mother and they're
different kinds of grandmothers my dad's
mother was
on me she my dad's mother ironed his
underwear until she got out of high
school
very nice people they traveled
uh my dad's father was uh you know he
ran social services for our part of iowa
they they got educations they they had
money they traveled uh they were part of
the be of service to their community
uh and you know really wonderful people
my my grandfather was uh
you know in the war he was one of the
first people into doc out
my mother's side is jewish my my
granddad's side
isn't but he you know they had and my uh
dad's my uncle wrote the book the secret
life of adolf hitler
made that documentary um but my mother's
side
uh they were they were working class my
grandfather on my mother's side
worked at the meatpacking plant for 45
years
and the the jewish there was four jewish
families where i'm from and they were
working
class people the the four cohen sisters
that moved to this part of iowa
uh many years many years ago they
assimilated into the working you know
they were they were
and that's what we did and uh and so
uh you know i worked at a pork
processing plant for
to save money for college that's that's
what we did so but my grandmother my
mother's mother
um who uh did not get her driver's
license after my grandfather
died and just didn't do you know it's
different
but she and this is a key with kids kids
know if you don't want to be with them
yes they do and she wanted to be with me
i mean she didn't say much but she would
sit on the couch with me
and we would whether we watched tv
together or whether she
cut up beans or whether whatever we were
doing because you know
we're from farm country she want i knew
she wanted to be that's really
interesting you say that because there's
so much put into
verbal communication these days and
everything but you're [ __ ] right
yeah maybe sometimes nothing said
between two people who just want to be
together and be present with each other
is more powerful than sitting there
having [ __ ]
you know small talk yeah that's right
i've never even thought of that before
how powerful it is that
i want to be with maybe she doesn't know
how to communicate so well or whatever
but yeah you felt that
that need to be present that's that's
yeah wow yeah that's awesome
and she also uh and uh
she also fed me whatever i wanted to eat
impressed by my eating and you know
because my dad just did not know how to
cook both my grandmothers were
great that way and you know it's funny
because my grandfather my mother's
father was a big
big guy and he was big into sports and
tough for the
plant and tough and uh
you know i saw him get into more than
one fight
he's tough and uh you know if you're a
big tough jew and a big
you know [ __ ] you know if you're from a
small town ed
you're different at all like i didn't
have a mother so people say stuff so my
grandpa
i'm sure had to step up and get into
you know but my grandmother
that you know he also got stern with me
a few times
you know and and i do remember my
grandmother
even if he got crabby with me
just looking at him and you because you
think well this is the woman that didn't
even get to drive she doesn't get to
have
i bet he keeps her in this but uh
i i saw her do things to him without
saying anything
where he'd be like oh
you know listen you're her favorite
i don't i mean he just would be she
could crush him
he he and you know i he has a right to
go
you know uh you know there's some things
sometimes i did stuff wrong
i got in some trouble sometimes i but if
he got
just crabby with me as as men
tend to do then she'd
he'd come back outside into whatever and
say listen
god damn it
you know i mean he just you know you're
your favorite you just tell that she'd
put it back out there and but i'd sure
love being with him
i just loved being around him i loved
going to games with him i loved
so we all were us kids uh
were look at looked after uh uh in
different ways
and then when i was 10 when we i was ted
my dad married the next door neighbor
now i did it yeah yeah hold on can we
talk about this for a second yeah
our 20s were a while ago 22
with three [ __ ] kids all under what
five
at the time my brother wasn't even one
and uh wow yeah and dad sounds like a
strong man well
he is and uh i at the time i i do
remember
saying god you're boring you know you
come we were
you know you work at the factory and uh
and then we want you to play with us
more and he would get on the floor
and play with us you know but he did
work
a lot and uh you know you always want
more
and i think about that now because you
know
i became father of 54 and you know he
didn't he didn't
pretty well you know yeah in our town
too i have to say
that uh it's very uh uniontown
and uh i i remember my dad he worked so
hard
and he did he finally got he was
management
i have to say he finally saved enough
body because he had to drop out of
college when my mom said she was
pregnant so when she was 16
my uncle went on very successful my
aunt went to new york actress on tv and
broadway
my dad dropped out of school to take
care of us so he earned his degree
slowly slowly but uh his plant went on
strike
and he he just gotten this mercury
marquee
convertible used and he was so proud of
it
and he parked it in the driveway and our
cousin was one of the men that blew it
up
there was a strike and then the police
and it was like my dad was so
because my dad was in a show off and he
was the youngest bro
that was family and they blew it up and
it was
the cops had to wait till they did it
they were outside they knew it was gonna
happen
and it incinerated it and my dad
you know uh you know because my dad did
time study he was an industrial engineer
so he said
well if you make this many pieces of
this uh industrial knife you'll make
this
amount of money and if you work this
fast very you know it's numbers
it wasn't like he was you know and and
man the
the union guys with just
you know you know
it was my cousin tommy richmond tommy
richard
but you know we but again when i when i
grew older
and hormel my beatback plant was right i
was
you know you worked there at hormel that
was where you did the fork
yeah the most famous strike at b-pack
flat strike ever
uh you know i was so excited i was like
yeah
we're gonna i don't even know what the
strike's about but i am all in because
it's gonna get
crazy you know and then of course they
fired everybody and just changed the
name on the outside of the building to
excel and hired people have to but
you know it's a very intense uh you know
but my dad did i mean there's so many
things
i think about him uh god and i and i'll
tell you what right i always thought
this too
because my mom you know she would sort
of she had this allure and the next door
neighbor that he married
who had two kids who i don't since they
were bored he asked us
he sat down and said do you mind if i
marry ruth how old are you at that time
nine and uh she babysat us i mean she's
from a different world you know she's
more of a
uh you know uh air base is sort of a
redneck but she's more of a hillbilly
you know she's smaller
rio and she'd uh she she was big on the
corporal punishment that we don't think
we'd ever had that and uh
you know uh and i think she was younger
sort of when she
hit you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and she'd
grown up that way and she was not
my dad she was younger than my dad so
she was even closer to my
age and i was the oldest and i think she
uh and i i'm sure i was a handful but
you know i was a kid
i think she said well i'm gonna break
this one and uh you know very
and uh but we did tell them yeah because
we like
you know felt bad for him because you
know dating
was hard and uh and i i he had the best
of intentions like my sister
you know did not have a female influence
on a daily basis but she was so rough
you know i remember
laurie uh tackling her once because my
dad said
you have to put on clean underwear every
day she told us all of us
and i tackled her from behind i pulled
down the back of her
pants and she had like five different
she was putting on clean underwear
on top of her underwear and my mom was
not a feminine
you know [ __ ] my mom said two things i'm
not maternal
so and i'm not gonna tell you i love you
but i will tap you on the knee once well
that's the signal
but then she was rough people are kind
of rough you know the
the i it'll be rough to insult that it's
like the
but the the the the women uh uh there's
you know we compete uh there's a lot of
uh a barrel rope and
and we could be those are competitive
sports for you know you grow up the
the women work the girls work on the
farm with their dad if their dad dies
the girl takes over it's not like
you go oh shoot i gotta find a boy no no
they're doing it with you whatever
you do when you go out the fields of
work that your sister is doing it
standing next to you with a bus when you
go down to the church parking lot
to get on the bus with the drifters
that's what you do every summer to go
details on court
your sister's with you there's no they
don't go girl it's gonna be easier for
you
no she's with you and girls softball
basketball when i was growing up in iowa
are way more popular
we're way you though state tournaments
are way more popular than the boys were
because they you know they were they're
better uh
they're better athletes they're a better
team you know the appeal just cared more
uh so you know it's hard to tell
you know uh who they're just rough but
my dad also wanted
you know he felt bad that she doesn't
have the
you know you want to be around you want
to have a a female
in your life and she was so
that was that's what i guess he thought
of a lot of things he thought i'm gonna
do this could be the best thing it was
rough for me and i ended up moving out
and uh
moved grandparents the next year
wow but i moved in with his parents his
parents
who are my grandma was super nice
super nice and the first day
i was at school and i came home with a
black eye because that's what happens in
school
to boys they get in a fight and they
have a black eye and i didn't think
anything about it
and i'm eating dinner with my grandpa
and my grandma and all of a sudden she
puts her head down and starts weeping
and my grandma's like what
what's going on it's because i had a
black eye i didn't even know that
like i'd gotten a fight no big deal and
then i remember thinking
oh she's going to be weeping all the
time
because you know it was a rough
rough town and and uh i
might be able to live here because
that's another side
you go you go for people that uh have
animus towards you
to people that care so much that wow
i'd rather be somewhere in the middle
and and also at that time
i i did you know you look at these
people that are like these eskimos these
angels
and i did get uh i wasn't popular
again if you don't have a mother if
you're different
if you're and there were the older kids
and i'm
i guarantee i brought you know i because
i brought it on myself and you
there's a lot of growing up a lot of
fighting a lot of fists
boys tons yeah so
you know i got uh chased out of that uh
school
towards hope and at the bottom of the
hill for my grandmothers was
saint mary's catholic church and uh
you know i don't i didn't know obviously
i didn't go there but
they had a young priest who just got to
town and uh
you know i and he see me get cha you
know fighting and getting chased up
towards there
and uh he was out outdoors uh uh
father gary was his name but he knows
i'm not catholic obviously and and uh
you shoot baskets i saw i watched him a
couple times as i
ran up the side street to my grandma and
said he saw me
one day he said hey you want to shoot
hoops and i did
he didn't say anything to me and i did
it started doing it every day
and he never said anything but it was
just him and i
i didn't know it changed my life
because he was cool this is a
good-looking dude cool
and and also with those other guys who
wanted to kill me saw him
they stopped because he's also big yeah
and they're like what what the hell is
going on what's the deal with this guy
you know this guy is uh you know he's a
preacher and he's big
and he's like athletic and he's arnold's
friend
who's not he then they would start it
then he stopped
like he's his buddy okay let's do so
we're not we're not gonna
you know but he never said hey uh
go away pretend he didn't know i was
going i would have been embarrassed
but we shot he shot a lot and then uh
you know
it was you know it was it was but it was
a big deal
to me to have somebody that just said so
they'd go hey
if you're getting beat up i would have
said no no no that's not happening
no this this guy i'm not no you know
people that when i grow up their parents
would bring them down to fight me get up
you better get out of this because
they're crazy they are crazy
i'm like god dang it let me know how i
go no they're just
vicious people that yeah but they're
also
you know our town was divided you know
they're straight up
the straight up racist our next door
neighbor
dog was a big black pitbull and his name
was the n-word that's that's not
there's no irony that it got lost a lot
there's
those people and then there's people
like
us who just hated because they're so
embarrassed
so there's the people like us there was
four black families too four jewish
so they were our friends and we just
hated them because they're freaking
embarrassing
and that's how every in sports
in dodge ball we were divided up you
know
greaser and also did you smoke pot or
did you drink because you couldn't do
both
but we just hated those people now until
i got out of my town
i didn't know there was any other kind
of racism except straight up
edward racism black and white yeah just
saying those
just people that say that word because
they're scumbags so they have no teeth
and they're disgusting but even being
jewish you didn't experience it there
they just it's too small not enough
juice to hate you know
we had that's true we had uh you know
you hate
you say things and with my grandpa's
generation they're sort of a
secret uh you know you know
thing and i knew enough about it from uh
you know funny funny enough for my other
grandpa from
what he brought back from dachau and
what he uh you know because that had
changed his
life and and you know but in
they plus he they didn't want to talk
about it you know
but uh you it's really true and then as
you get out you know but but all
but those people that uh said the edward
that'll be they said a lot of
[ __ ] and a lot of stuff and you just
kind of went well they those guys are
the most ignorant
[ __ ] that we ever met in our life
they're getting they're so stupid
you know that they're like you know they
hate
everything and everyone but we don't
want anyone to ever see them
they grew up with them right seriously
that's what it is they are so
embarrassing
uh we don't want anybody to know they're
white like we don't we need to put a sh
a cone over i know this they're
embarrassing to
humanity and like
i mean i can't even explain to you how
it is to be
you know and then but i saw some of
their kids go
go on and come to school with us and
want to do better
and do better and then so i had a lot of
compassion
you know uh for the kids because they
were really struggling
with their parents geez and so i always
felt like well you know i had it
you know things could have been a lot
worse you know some kids want to get out
of the the alcoholism someone to get out
of the
fricking crazy
racism which is a disease like it is
you know and so you just want to go i'm
going to
do i'm going to try to pull away from
this let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first spots or upstart now
during these economically turbulent
times
everyone is looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still
needlessly throwing money away every
month at high interest credit card debt
it's time you checked out
upstart the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score now is the time
to find out how low
your upstart rate can be to help pay off
high interest credit card debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree
or a diploma to apply though upstart
lets you skip going to the bank because
it's completely online they offer loans
from a thousand dollars to fifty
thousand dollars so you can consolidate
your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple
to check your rate and since it's just a
soft pool it won't affect your credit
score the hard pull
happens if you accept your rate and
proceed with your application and the
best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day
over 400 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt and get back
to using your money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of 5 rating on trustpilot
and hurry to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is omax living
with chronic pain is the worst it's more
than a feeling of discomfort it can
affect your whole life many of you
probably have some type of pain that's
prevented you from relaxing
and sleeping or stopped you from
exercising perhaps it's been ongoing for
a few weeks now
and it hasn't improved with any of the
treatment you tried i just went to the
doctor today i got what's called trigger
finger it's been popping on me down here
this tendon been popping off i've been
taking omax cryo freeze
putting it right on there and i promise
you it's making a difference all right
enter oh max health if you're looking to
get rid of nagging muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long-lasting
recovery then you need to try the
natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryo-free cbd roll-on developed
by omax health
this non-prescription triple action pain
relief roll-on is specially formulated
to block pain receptors reduce
inflammation and improve muscle
and joint flexibility and the best part
is this 100 natural cbd powered remedy
works its magic within 10 minutes of
application
and relief lasts up to eight hours which
is much longer
than the over-the-counter products omax
health is offering my listeners 20
off a full bottle of cryo-free cbd pain
relief roll-on this discount
also applies towards any product
site-wide so go to omaxhealth.com and
enter code honeydew to get 20
off cryo-freeze and site-wide i'm
telling you
this product is the real deal so go to
omax health.com
and enter code honeydew to get 20
percent off and
site wide and i just want to give a a
little special attention and shout out
to my my good friend gary adler who
launched a new comic book company called
odd one out the first series of comic
books they're publishing is commando
place and what i have here
in my hands is commando place number one
finding konishiki
this debut comic is 53 pages of
incredibly beautiful art with a unique
and diverse cast of characters it's set
in a parallel universe
the heroes toggle between the video game
world and the real world it sounds crazy
but it's funny as hell
go to kickstarter.com you can search
commando place and
let's help gary get the next five of
these books made if you're a fan of doom
patrol or the boys
you're gonna love commando place and now
you can be part of its success go to
kickstarter.com
and search commando place get out there
night pants nation see if you can't help
them achieve their goal
or if you just want to read the comic
there's no pressure you just go to
amazon.com
and you can search commando place and
order yours
today now let's get back to the do
you know i mean how does it affect you
as a father today
see where you started fatherhood at 54.
yeah first child of 54.
i did um you know it was a long journey
because i've tried uh
uh you know i found out in college that
i could not be a father
uh the the normal way how did you find
it well i
went to university of iowa and i worked
at the hospital school
and uh for a job i donated blood and
plasma
a lot for beer buddy you know at both
hospitals children's and the u of i
and uh and uh i uh at any time be on the
board they'd have different things
for students for different jobs you
could donate you'd be part of experiment
like me my buddies were up for
whatever and uh um uh uh one time
that i they said donate bone barrel
they needed it for one of the kids they
wanted to test and i i stopped there
and uh uh it was 75 it was the most i'd
ever seen for something
and i was like yes nobody even signed up
and i put my name first
you get your name first on a these
things it's like if you work at a meat
packing plant there's a
different union if jobs available you
put your name on it you can move up
if you work in a bee packet plant you
you start in
livestock where it's so bad because
there's so much dog
hog [ __ ] everywhere you go inside to the
kill floor where there's less
hog [ __ ] and then you hopefully get in
somewhere where it's refrigerated
and then you go to the smoke shop where
you can eat actual food
that you're actually cutting so it's
always about moving up
within the the factory so i see this 75
dollars
for for bone barrel yes that will be uh
and then
and so then i'm the only person signed
up and the nurses
that i work with at the hospital school
were not
super fans because i was so you know
that they were like
oh tom you you're doing that i go yeah
well yeah i'm doing it
uh of course you're our hero i go am i
okay and so i was like well that feels
good i've always liked to get blood and
whatever else and i did a
sleep test for you guys which was uh
you know i'll do anything for these kids
and and so that i went to the
they took me to the room to give the the
blood sample
i thought for the bone marrow and uh the
the two nurses who i was i loved but
they always screwed with the the doctor
comes
in he goes arnold's doing this yeah and
he turns her he goes listen i can give
you a local
i i i can dub that area but
it's still going to hurt like a
[ __ ] that's what the doctrine
said
and that nurse had pulled my my uh
loosened up my belt and pulled it down
to my hip
and i was like this something
something's up but he turns around
you know i should know this from being
on a farm he had one of those corkscrew
needles
and i'm like you got to be kidding me
and
they he screwed it at the time this is
1980
i was like now you now i could have and
uh this is
people that work at the hospital still
know this story i could have run out
like i could have pushed out i could
have run out for
75 yeah 75 to 1980 though
but i and the nurses they're looking
straight at me like
you but it it also it was for
potentially to say something i know i
guarantee it did it but
it was a test you know although i am
still a
bow barrel donor i've seen that in my
way ago but
this is back in the day they much easier
way if you want to be a bone marrow
donor if they don't do this
there's no way you have to do it this
way to test you i'm just going to tell
you right now
to get it you know there's a and so
there everybody's looking at me like are
you if i ran out there i'd have to never
work at the hospital so i'd lose my job
i'd have to probably quit school
i mean you don't and so i just it was it
was
so painful oh like right in the bone
yeah but
but so then right after that i uh
and then everybody's like yeah they just
screw right in the boat i mean it stops
hurting at a certain point
because uh but you know uh
but right but soon after that there was
a site said 35
for sperm and they started a new
fertility clinic there
and i was like well that is and so i
called my five roommates
and i was like i can't believe our luck
i'm gonna do this three times a day we
went
running over there and they're like slow
down
we have to test yours for that i was
like that that has to be easier
and then uh you know and they the doctor
came back and said listen
uh i got some bad news we we're never we
you don't have you don't have enough
you know sperm and i and uh you'll never
get a woman pregnant the normal way
basically break it down
you have like four or three and i go
that seems like it'd be enough and he
goes your roommate has two million i go
that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] like they they my i'm
still buddies these guys i go
she'll never get a woman pregnant the
the normal way and and
uh yeah i was i was down about the
which is weird because now i'd be
thinking what happened to that sperm
you know but then i'm thinking well i
just want to make a bunch of money i'll
do it all the time
but uh uh i but then i also thought well
this is
also good news because and i there was
many times we'd be at the
bar closing and uh i i'd say to women
yeah uh
yeah i can't uh i don't know if you
heard by can't you pregnant
like i maybe maybe uh sweat on you and
give you a staph infection but that's
about it like that was a calling
like in case you haven't heard yeah
you don't have to worry about me but i i
want to do it one time
also i live with my grandmother my
father's mother who was furious
catholic woman who was like those are
your children those are your children i
thought the same thing i'm doing this
five times a [ __ ] day but what i
didn't know that i found out when i
started
i never ended up doing it but what i
didn't know is that
you're only allowed to donate a certain
amount of times
in a certain mile radius because
mathematically
it's possible that those two children do
meet up
and then they're ancestral kids and
everything else so
i was like well that just sucked all the
thunder out of this if i can only jerk
off three times like
that's right that's what's that uh
that's 105 dollars and it's a wrap on
that
well that's probably now that's not in
iowa
no this was back yeah that's right the
late 90s but i hadn't even
done the math on something like that
well you know
so when i got married uh to rosette i i
uh you know i've i've said
i really want a family you talk about
that before you get married
rosette had kids and she part of my
attraction to her was
she was a great mom you know we met in
1983 when i was 23
and i don't think she was 30 then back
in the midwest she wasn't even famous
and
and we just hit it off we partied
a lot and i just moved from iowa and i
think she liked me because
i was a guy that would just you know i
was so different
i wasn't that far out of the meat
packing plant and and she was also
so different she was this mom and she
was like a feminist
and uh she was and i really respected
her and her she was so funny
her act was so funny and she did the
thing that
that men love more than anything we know
we're good-looking
but she she she thought i was funny and
that's a
if you want a man to love you and follow
you around forever
you tell him how funny he is you're
right because we're like i know
and you know and i also uh and i think
you're like this too
i you know we i stood up for her no
matter what i mean that was just how i
am
and when i came out to write her show
because it was her show
and she was always right because it's
her show
it's a show about her life and the
problems on the show were
uh that there were uh guys there she
never got created by credit on her
show and so at first
you know it you know i started off
writing jokes for her back
you know when i first met her and that
to see her doing those jokes on
johnny carson was like wow you know my
friend is
killing it and doing jokes that i wrote
and then eventually i came out to
write her tv show and then anytime there
was problems
i didn't understand exactly the finesse
how it works in hollywood and uh
neither did she obviously but i i knew
that
it was her show about her life and you
know i
obviously i put the iowa stuff in uh
a lot of the iowa stuff where i'm from
and and uh
but so she was right and she was funnier
than them and it's her life
so i'd say listen i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell you something you're gonna
you're gonna do it her way or else i
don't know how else to say this but
i'm [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm gonna throw
somebody out the [ __ ] window i'll
eventually
or you're fired or whatever i'm gonna
you know kick somebody's ass i don't
know
next year maybe i'll i'll learn some
more finesse but
what do you not understand about the
show
is called roseanne and you gotta quit
[ __ ] with her because
you're [ __ ] with me and i just don't
know
i don't know how how much more clear i
could make this if they were stunned
because i think they'd used to but i was
all in
i was like because she was right there's
no
and then it was uh uh you know then i
bought it brought a bunch of my friends
out for the midwest to write the show
half and then i found an executive
producer
with me that i trusted that brought half
of old
school guys from hollywood i said well
i'm gonna mix i'm gonna
teach my friends to write the form
because i know how funny they are
they've each got unique funny voices
and then to write the form of a sitcom
script it's a form
you learn to do that but you can't teach
people to be funny
and write in these different voices and
then i also want people that respected
her that respected her character
right and uh but i also needed to i
didn't want a [ __ ] show i didn't want to
go
well i'm gonna we're gonna recreate the
stand-up comedy
or sitcoms we're gonna completely
but we had to we had to produce a
different a new show every week
and they're so like well we're just
gonna no every week it had to be turned
in and i was aware of that too
so you know i mean it was you have
you have to get out of here in a little
bit yeah so i want to get you to
i want to talk to you about being a dad
yeah well you know anyway
i i i know so 23 so you still try
oh yeah you did so ed rosette we did i
said let's not do
uh in vitro i don't want you put your
body through that it's by
my issue we tried six times and failed
and
the great thing about my first three
wives a total of 20 times
failed and the great thing about each
one of them
uh got remarried right away to another
guy and had a baby with that guy
the normal way so i'm grateful that they
did it
and and i'll tell you something else
that happened we went to an adoption
lawyer
and and this happened each time ed
sheridan stoned
another great friend of mine said hey
because adoption takes a while
that sharon stone said listen i want you
to go to my adoption attorney he got
my great boys he will expedite the
process
and and you know adoption you know you
could have a baby if your marriage isn't
perfect the regular way people do it all
the time and
and and in vitro is so stressful
it's the hormones the couple is stressed
out
things might not be perfect when you
have that baby it's a blessing
but adoption here's the thing that baby
has options
so you the question is is your marriage
are you good enough
for that baby because people go i'm
going to get adopt a baby and then i'm
going to make
that a great point your baby is your
baby but someone else's has
a lot of options your kids just got you
yeah
yeah so we so rosetta i went to
this uh lawyer and i thought well maybe
it'll take uh
six months instead of two years whatever
and we're like well we'd like to adopt
and he's like
when i said well you know asap he went
to his computer and he pulls his picture
off he goes
how about in 45 minutes come on this
baby is just born in wisconsin to a 15
year old girl and i
i i tore the picture off she handed it
to us i was
looking at a picture of this beautiful
little red-haired little baby boy
and uh i said uh to rosanna youth do you
think we're good enough for that
for that baby and uh i die and she could
tell
and she's like no i go i don't think so
either then we got divorced
that's why we got divorced really yeah
and that's basically what happened
with my first three marriages we were
not good enough our marriage wasn't good
enough
to adopt a child so that's what it was
time to request
yeah but when i was 54 i didn't want to
do i want to do a sperm donor by the way
because
shaquille o'neal was my next-door
neighbor for eight years that's no joke
you got it there's no headshot there's
no joke
and you know in iowa if you wanted to
borrow a cup of sugar this is a fact
you went to your neighbor's door and you
said hey neighbor
can i borrow a cup of sugar and you know
those cups you get for the fertility
clinic
i swear on my life we live on a
cul-de-sac i thought how hard would it
be
for me to go get a cup of shack and i
swear this is no joke
i just want and here's what i think
about god about it
i think our babies are out up there
we're all up there and
my whole life i've been waiting for my
kids and i've been
you know and however my child
however i'm blessed you know it might be
a seven foot tall black son
it might be a whatever it might be
through adoption whatever that soul
whatever if
it if it comes it may not be in this
lifetime maybe
whatever and yeah how lucky
you know i i'm not go oh well wait a
minute just have my dna
my dna is [ __ ] up my dna is alcoholism
and crazy
whatever uh you know
however the baby came you know however
blessed if i get
and if it doesn't work out i'm so
blessed away and so
uh when i met that ashley the mother of
my kids you know
she said i'm going to make sure you have
a baby but she's
uh if whatever worked whatever the
relationship was like
you know looking back she uh said we're
you're gonna
do this and she uh made it happen and
what happened is we
tried the in vitro three times and then
the doctor said that is
there's nothing i could do and i said
well i i just
i i don't i i never on a i said too bad
there's not something you could do on a
man
and he goes well i'd like to this is
brilliant doctor yes
well there's something i'd like to
experiment on a man
and i was like and i i saw her looking
like yeah let's do that i go
the doctor's very good friend he's he's
worked on roseanne and i
all these people and he goes i go well
what do you want to do and
the way my son came into this world is
i they cut my scrotum in half which i we
should have just done this day one
and took a big syringe which is much
like the
other story and stuck it into my
testicle
and pulled one sperm out come on and
they happen to have one of her eggs
and thank uh this is a miracle and they
put them together and
it started multiplying and it's a
miracle
miracle and kept multiplying and then
they took that and they put it
uh in a per uh hoo-ha or whatever and
even without the sticky hormones it just
started
it stayed one month two months and i got
so
nervous everybody's just wow what a gift
and uh
uh uh every month to see
more more than a heartbeat and then so
nervous
and uh and and i remember it was time to
go to the hospital and get there the
doctor's like
uh uh just everything's fine
he's fine but but uh i was like oh my
god but he's breach
so uh we're gonna we're gonna do a
c-section so
tom you're gonna want to you're gonna
want to stay behind that curtain because
you don't want to see this and i was
like
buddy i worked at a meatbag
i am not going anywhere i got to see
this because i just don't believe it's
happening
and it was so amazing and and the second
you know uh the second i see you know
cause because i'm also on point like
what if something goes sideways i've
delivered
just something you don't want to tell
your wife for telling me i've delivered
a lot of animals
a lot of calves oh yeah a lot of horses
a lot and
it's wonderful i'd say this man and
sometimes things go sideways
and it does you got to be in there you
know the vet the vets there whatever
people you got there but sometimes you
got to put a knee under
you got to bear down and sometimes you
can see you know
it's always wonderful you know we raise
cattle we raise horses we raise and
uh i know it sounds delta but
i'm always also on alert because that's
your wife that's your baby right there
you don't just assume that everybody
here knows what they're doing
right i mean you're on point so uh and
the way to do a c-section my
because it because you know here's what
you do if you think oh my god i can't
take it because it is hard
it is hard to see a doctor just let it
be a matter of fact cuddy
oh you're right so what you do is you
they put a circle around it and you go
that's not her
belly they're not cutting that's where
the baby could they put a circle around
it
and go that circle is a whole separate
thing
that's where the baby comes from that
circle you don't identify it with the
person you take it out
and you compartmentalize it and so
that's what you do but anyway
he comes out and i i help get him out of
there
what does that feel like well
it changed everything first of all
i uh you know you go back to your
childhood
and there's uh it just
i mean it's everything first of all you
go
uh i was at
perfect at one time and that small and
and you really are shocked that that uh
you know you look back on your uh you
think wow uh
you know because there's things that
happen in your childhood you you you
kind of
go well you know i was this got a kid or
that kind of kid and
and it's it's it's hard to believe that
you were also perfect like that that's
how
you were and it's also you realize oh my
god
i care about everything about this
kid and and the way you had it i mean
yeah that's a that's a lotto it's a
miracle and
you know a little thought later was my
dad also cared about everything
oh i used to say well uh you know i got
in so much trouble i got arrested
sometimes
once i'm a teenager fighting the cops
fighting
drinking fighting and then he had to be
able to be out of jail he had to bail me
out of jail and
i'd be like well he doesn't he doesn't
care he doesn't he does he just
he cares he had to get up he had to get
my other cousin was a cop he'd be like
he cared i go yeah he had cares because
he couldn't sleep and i realized
uh you just he cared
because you care about everything and uh
and i you know every moment and i was
funny because i was cutting the cord
and uh and my son wrapped his fingers
around the
scissors i almost like cut his fingers
off right there i was like oh geez
and so every but every second
and you know my friend said listen he
would you know let
your wife at the time do everything but
it was seven they'd come back he's he'll
be 47. and i said well yeah i'm 54. i
don't know where i'll be when he's seven
so i've changed every diaper and stay
with my daughter who is
a miracle there's a frozen embryo what
is after the relationship edited tell me
how you had her
uh is this guy tyler henry
i think the hollywood medium i didn't
show my ex
asked me to do a favorite show to get a
reading from him and
he came over and i i did not believe i
don't believe in
that he's also a uh one of the people
that's talked to dead people
he's uh uh whatever they're called eddie
and she liked his show medium yeah he
walks in my house and he goes like this
your mother is here and she is sorry
which is like an evergreen yes
but anyway at the end he does this
reading and i wanted to bust him
but she's like big into this so i
thought i'll you know for her whatever
and i go hey tyler you got it got any
questions yeah if i could have another
child
or we which we weren't having sex we
weren't together we weren't
and i knew that my dad he's like this
yes you are this is on the tv show so
you see
i go really ah a boy or girl he goes
a girl and i was like oh my god this is
the best thing i've ever cause
it's impossible physiology i walk him in
the door and then
because she's never said i was right
about anything she goes
i guess you're right he's full of [ __ ]
like he's
he's her idol he's your idol and then
and then this is no [ __ ] uh 48 hours
later i get a call from a cryobank and
long beach and we use this other doctor
in between dr mars that's our main guy
just because
i don't know if he was out of town and
they had a frozen embryo stored down
there they were looking for me to pay
700 bucks i'd owe them and i changed
business managers
they had it and so she heard about it
drives down there
100 miles an hour gets that shot up into
her
hoo-ha and would nine months later to
the day
my daughter was born holy [ __ ] i'll tell
you man
i don't know it is crazy because it is i
was i thought i'm gonna
you gotta survive no matter what no kids
i thought man i've been so blessed and
you know and then my son i was like okay
that is
everything and i did have a couple
people say well you know
daughters are i don't know i had to have
and i'll tell you what
i'm glad i have a daughter i said hey
she's also a great son i have to tell
you like
by such she's also by far the funniest
but it's also how close they are
you know i i i designed decorated the
rooms that they wanted and we both sites
are still the same
bed but the way they i just see them
together you know when i get out of bed
to
pee which is more than they just moved
together i
she she is his biggest fan you know he's
a big he's a
115 pounds he just got out of
kindergarten he's a head taller
she's small she doesn't take any [ __ ]
but you i watch out for that but she is
uh
you know i make sure she gets her he
sucks up a lot of air
and i've always made sure one day a week
is just me and her
but they love each other so much because
i feel like this
is a you know this is a an incubator
for every relationship they'll ever have
and you know she hasn't seen
she never saw her mom and i hug or
she doesn't know how that works said you
know after bob
officially moved out after you know i i
showed the videos
of uh her birth i went through and she
like how did i get here
and i said love you know we loved you so
much and
we wanted you know that i made a little
cartoon of
your bob i was born over here you're in
heaven you guys
and i wanted that your mom was born much
later
much younger but we wanted you to be
here and then here you are
and that's how you came from love and we
both dreamed about you guys and then we
we came together and she goes and then i
was in mommy's
belly i got away you started you know
here i made it very clear
you got it yeah yeah yeah oh no i
don't know i go you started here yeah
yeah but i i want you to know that that
you absolutely came from
love because that's really important
yeah and that's where you know
and then your brother came first said
that we that we all
were waiting for you and i literally
have a i went down and because her mom
had a tough delivery with her
the first four hours was they had i had
to take up my shirt like in front of
it i was gonna do that kind of emergency
and uh hold her for
a few hours put her on before then i
went home got a little brother
and brought him down first time and i
have it all on
video and uh it is so i'm so glad i have
that
because i've been splading uh you know
and then we came down and got you and uh
and and to see you and it's uh and uh
she said i go do you remember that she
goes kind of
and uh you know but she does remember me
making her bottles
at night because of i bring her back
downstairs and she remembers
what's well she'll say can i have a
bottle tonight
just once i don't know if it kids once a
while they want to be
babied i'm always like yeah
yeah i love it i can tell you love it i
do i can tell you appreciate it
i appreciate it yeah i wish my i'm
have a similar upbringing in the sense
that my mother split early my dad was a
single dad but he died when we were 16.
so then we
we've got nobody we live with his mom
that sort of thing but
you know i'm a twin i'm a fraternal twin
but i wish when my daughter was born
i was just like i wish he was here how
the [ __ ] did you do it
twins then another kid like you know and
i i wish i had
some him not someone [ __ ] him to
bounce
questions off of ideas off of like hey
when i [ __ ] up and did this
what would you what would you have liked
to have done differently
you know how can i better parent better
teach
um well look you we got to get you out
of here all right every minute but i
have a question for you i ask all my
first time guests this um
after everything you've said after
everything you've been through what
advice would you give to your 16 year
old self
with the with the benefit of hindsight
well easy does it
uh you know
i mean every dream i've ever had has
come true i
i think um
you know i've gotten very lucky about
surviving uh
um you know
i think i i identified a dream and then
i
whether it be watching my dad watch bob
hope on tv and laugh and go
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna make my dad
laugh on tv
with bob hope beside me or whatever it
was
uh just easy
easy doesn't beware of of got very lucky
you know
barely you know god was
very very lucky i got to uh
um i would have got married so much save
saved save some money uh
but i hate to change that sequence
of things uh you know
i like the easy does it i mean it
changes nothing about your life
in the course of it just try to relax a
little [ __ ] yeah i wish i i'm still
i don't remember i don't mean surrender
mm-hmm
you know yeah but uh because i do think
that
when you're a parent you got to be ready
you got to be because
sometimes you have to stand up we live
in a world where
you know uh you gotta you gotta be
it's like what i said about roseanne
with the show i gotta hey listen man
you gotta have people's backs you
whisper you're with people you gotta
have their backs
you they i got these kids backs you know
i'd like to just uh you said about have
the energy well i have to have the
energy there's no excuse
i've got to do it and i can sit around
and say well i'm 61.
um they don't care they look at you like
how do they what would they do about
that nothing i got to do it all
i got to do it all i gotta get on the
ground and play with him like my dad did
i gotta go outside play with him we
gotta
play ball we gotta kick the ball you
gotta box we gotta
you know carry him up by still son makes
him can't be carrying about the stairs
115 that kind of weight like you know
that is with both of them yeah you know
it's like uh
i can't tell you if my shoulders are
always hurting i got to switch sides
yeah i'm like oh yeah man well good for
you
congratulations too but please plug
everything you want to plug everything
well you know uh sasha boggs
is great comedienne and great she's
great with the kids
she lives with us uh we have a great
podcast
uh called tom arnold two of the bush
she's a delight
we love her so much she's 30. she's
adorable
my friends all call hey are you guys
having sex i go
no and there i didn't think so she's
really cute and young
i go wait a minute we could
seriously so we did that we do this
podcast and you can see it on
youtube i think or uh spotify or
whatever and it's going very well and
she's so funny we're working there and i
was like hey you did a podcast right
i saw in your thing and it's so funny
let's do one here
because we're quarantined with these
kids let's do a podcast
and talk about everything she's so much
younger she knows nothing you understand
right
and uh she's so funny and then uh but
she's so good at the kids and
and uh and so we do that and then we
made a music video you gotta see his
music video
because uh kid's mom's like you should
send him to school rock cap this summer
i said
i am the school of rock half that's why
you talking to your neighbor
who i like has a music store yes i go we
do it all we have
i have rappers i have great filmmakers
that committed out of my place teaching
the kids stuff
so we made a rap video the kids like rap
music i don't know what kind of music
they do the tick tock yeah and so it's a
little filthy but i i have
i believe some of the words for the kids
thing but it's about our life
being quarantined this summer uh people
asking me if sasha and i are boating
and the kids and we used everything
about the house and
we had so much fun and uh but that's the
life and you know we're uh
i have a movie called high holidays
coming out in a month or so with
jennifer
tilly's my wife and the great cloris
leachman
is my mother-in-law a bunch of really
good actors and then
you know uh a lot of things whatever i
need to work ryan
i need to pay some bills i'd like to go
back and do some road
shows and i missed
okay let's do it thank you brother thank
you for coming on congratulations on the
podcast
and fatherhood uh ryansickler.com on all
social media
ryan sickler uh whatever it is
ryancicler.com we'll talk to y'all i'm
on twitter too yeah yeah twitter
instagram man i go hard on twitter
beware i will talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you